in this lesson you're going to learn how
to solve equations involving decimals
and we're going to talk about an easier
way to work with these by clearing the
decimals so let's go through two
examples together and I'll show you how
this works so for this first example
what you might notice is that there's a
lot of decimals in this equation another
thing you might notice is that there's
really like only one decimal place see
how this is like 9/10 and 4/10 and 210
so what we can do by to clear the
decimals is we can multiply through this
whole equation by the number 10 now the
nice thing about multiplying by 10 is it
moves the decimal one place to the right
making this now 9x and that's a whole
number which is a little bit easier to
work with you also want to make sure you
multiply the two by 10 and you don't see
the decimal that means it's understood
to be right here on the right side so if
I move that one place to the right this
is actually going to make this 20
because I have to put a zero as a
placeholder same thing here if I
multiply this guy by 10 that's going to
give us
24x and then this guy we multiply by 10
that's going to give us
82 now the reason this works is we're
keeping the equation balance it's like
we're multiplying the left side by 10
and we're also multiplying the right
side by 10 and so it's keeping the
equation balance just make sure you
multiply every single term by that
number 10 now it's a little bit easier
to solve with these whole numbers here
let's get the variables on one side and
the numbers on the other side so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to subtract
24x from both
sides so that's going to give us a -5x
and then I'm going to add 20 to both
sides so that's going to cancel out and
give us
102 okay now we just want to solve for
one of our variable by dividing by
-15 and let's see so x equals a negative
how many times does 15 go into
102 well let's see 7 * 15 is 105 that's
a little too much so this is going to be
6 * 15 * 6 is 90 with 12 left over so
that's going to be 6 and 12 15 we can
reduce the 12 uh 15 by dividing by three
that's going to come out to -6 and 4
FS you could also write this as
-6.8 since 4 divided 5 is uh 8/10 let's
take a look at number two now now number
two is a little bit different because
notice we have two decimal places we've
got tenths and hundreds same thing here
tenths and hundreds so what we can do
here is let's multiply through the whole
equation not by 10 but by a 100 and the
nice thing about multiplying by 100 is
it moves the decimal two places to the
right if you multiply by a th it moves
it three places to the right but in this
case we really only need to move it two
places this is a little bit trickier
problem because you see how this whole
quantity it's like a group so when we
multiply this group by 100 we're just
going to move this decimal point not the
on the three not on the Y just on the
.13 so that's going to give us
13 Yus 3 and here we're going to move
the decimal two places that's going to
give us 8 Y and here the decimal point
is right at the right side of the number
we're going to move that two places to
the right which is going to give us
500 okay now we've cleared the decimals
this is a little bit easier to work with
let's go ahead and do our distributive
property that gives us 13 y i -
39 and then we want to get the variables
on one side numbers on the other so
let's go ahead and get the variables on
the left by subtracting 8 y from both
sides that's going to give us 5 y then
we're going to add
39 to both sides to get the numbers on
the right so that's going to give us
539 and lastly we just want to solve for
one of our variable so instead of
multiplying by five let's divide both
sides by five and let's see 5 goes into
539 how many times looks like
107 with 4 left over so you could say
107 and 4 fths or if you wanted to write
it as a decimal that would be
107.8 and you got it so great job if you
want to see another example not working
with decimals but fractions where you
clear the denominators another nice
technique for solving equations follow
me over to that video I did right there
and we'll get some practice with that
I'll see you over there